in excess they to a I assigned this
question because it's interesting what's
interesting in fact if I already
seriously consider put it in something
like this won't give you this that's too
easy but can you see what's interesting
about it like it's this is what you're
asked to prove okay you know some points
any point on the ellipse actually and
they want to show they want you to show
that the distance from that point to
both of the focus okay when you add them
on so this distance Plus this distance
when you add a map apparently you get
the major axis that's 2a
isn't it okay and the reason why I like
it it's kind of a shame that I've shown
it to you because now I can't really do
the gritty matter is that there's no
formula to it it's no formula it's about
whether you understand the geometry of
this shape and how the features relate
to each other and there's no like okay
factorize this and then complete that
Square and then blah blah blah blah but
you can go through rather thoughtlessly
of mechanically doesn't you can't get
away with that on this kind of question
so how do you go about doing it okay now
I could just solve it for you okay
but that'd be a little bit boring
wouldn't it how are we going to network
with this thing okay where might you
start that the first thing I've done is
and if you have tried this question
without drawing it you are kidding
yourself okay if you have tried it and
have drawn like a little thing which is
you know like but it's this big and
you've got everything scratch tubes
you are still kidding yourself okay um
even if you don't actually label
anything on there the very active before
you often this is the same thing with
the circle geometry by the way you got
cell phone you interpret have you ever
had that where it's in the textbook then
you just stare at it you're like it's
been 10 minutes and I haven't gone
anywhere okay tip number one draw them
in and draw it be often the process of
drawing shows you the connections that
you need
what information could I add onto here
that might be used sorted well I've got
Pearson MPs - my 239 right and I have
them related to this point okay now I
want to keep in mind this is this is an
ellipse right so I know her heaps and
heaps of other stuff of information
about this and if somehow everything
lesser each other for instance today
it's the major axis yep so I
automatically now thinking about any
horizontal distances that are possibly
related to what I've got okay so for
instance think about this this is here I
think now by the way rather than say
this distance I want to put some names
on this okay because then I have
language to describe it so here's a
distance that it's important I'll call
it D 1 this distance here oh that's
really bad the drawing
oh well it's perpendicular yeah because
I said it is that distance that's
related to D 1 so I'm going to call it D
2 okay
this are the distance the other figures
we just call that D 3 I'm missing one I
guess I'll go to the other side Thanks
I'm gonna call this D ok now by the Ray
the reason why I'm going both ways okay
is because when I compare this distance
from this point to this focus I can't
just choose which directrix I want
there's one one direction and one
directions only that matches up with
this focus right and it's the one on
this side so these two match up do you
want do two and these two measure D do
evil all right now hmm let's see
do you wanna do - they're from quite
through the focus and the point to the
directrix how old do you have this in
your head they are related to each other
those distances D 1 and D 2 what's the
relationship between them we even give
it a name it's the X that is the
eccentricity right how would I write it
what ratio is it which ones which ones
on the top
it's this one it's PS on P wall this is
kind of D this is our this is what the
question said right but I'm not
rephrasing in terms of all this
different language on it okay so what I
have here if I'm going to be writing in
what I've got these are two distances
I'm often write d1 d3 okay so I somehow
want to connect these oblique lengths
with these horizontal legs
okay well the connection index
interested in okay so I suppose I could
write this as I can rewrite this I mean
useful way to round I'm gonna let you
think about that for a little while
no matter similar in the same way as I
said this I can also say the extra
intercept is equal to the other ratio
kana it should be the same d3 on d4 yes
all right I don't quite have all the
pieces there yet I have some
relationship between the length I'm
after and the links that I actually know
something about the horizontal ones okay
what else can I use here what else do we
know about this shape that we haven't
put on there they'll be useful to us
okay so the directrix director sees
rather they each have an equation don't
they
now the reason that we useful to us is
for two reasons number one the distances
between them are well-defined I can know
exactly where they are because I know
where these are right number two what
are the equations of the director suit
see you question of this one it's a Ani
then the other one is mine
a on e a and E okay I almost have all
the pieces in place the question is how
I put together think with me
this parts hard for me because I'm not
sure what next step to give you which
doesn't just completely spoil it okay I
want to give you a little clue which
will sort of push you over the edge but
you have to climb over that makes sense
d2 and d4 right they're not just random
once they're connected actually so I
actually know a whole lot about them d2
goes from all the way through to here
and so here and d4 goes all the way to
the other directrix okay so therefore I
what do you ever say that D 2 plus d 4
is equal to 2a on e because this is our
me and the absolute value of this is
also a linear those want to add the
lengths that's what I get to a or e keep
your eyes on where you need to get to
I'm really close to a there I just have
this evening there how am I gonna
rearrange it
okay so this D 2 in the d4 he's an
equation of state which I know is true I
somehow need to get rid of the d2 to d4
and yet the one in the 3 well I've got
enough pieces to do that don't I
how do I write this well I need to sub
out d2 so I'll make it the subject D 2
is equal to D 1 and then the he comes
down
similarly d 4 is d 3 on it these are
parallel standards so therefore I
suppose if I want to do properly let's
name this name that and say so I should
put on me sorry sorry if you want to do
it for me okay ready d1 on d3
that's interesting right month is part
of a question because it's very hard to
I'll ask a question about this but that
should tell you something interesting
about this why is it equal to the major
axis like a pre that algebraically but
how come a nice nap how come those two
are gonna give you that late what if I
moved P somewhere else or what happened
what would you expect to happen what if
I put P in unusual places like here or
here of special cases what would reveal
about the ellipse okay
this is the way I would do it probably
if I wanted to add one more thing I
would probably say at this point before
I save them I would say by definition or
if you want to be really formal by desh
definition on the locus of the ellipse
because that's where he comes from